syria's and device on my phone that
activates all the time and I don't want
to I don't have Siri because I have an
iPhone for me and Syria have never met
with Siri and I just started hanging out
like a week ago and she's the best how
do I even do it I just hold it down
what is 0/0 imagine that you have zero
cookies and you split them evenly among
zero friends how many cookies does each
person get
see it doesn't make sense and Cookie
Monster is sad that there are no cookies
and you are sad that you have no friends
oh that's pretty good that's pretty
clever
why are fire trucks red what because
they have eight wheels and four people
on them and four plus 8 is 12 and there
are 12 inches in a foot and one foot is
a ruler and Queen Elizabeth was ruler I
can clean a little bit a little blue
except Siri is messing with me and the
ship sailed the seas and then the seas
are fish and fish has been Finn's father
Russians and the Russians are red and
fire trucks are always rushing around oh
my god I feel like this is some sort of
cruel train that was like a really long
dad joke but does Santa Claus exist
let's just say I'm not the only one who
knows if you've been good or bad I'm
going to pretend you didn't ask that I
don't want you to get a lump of coal
this year just looking out for me what
does the Fox say
I think Syria to karaoke with me I
thought if anyone I was like this is the
only thing I've ever felt funny she's
got spunk she's got character is it
weird to say that I like the onesy
Stephanie I don't like to be sass by my
friends I don't need to be fast on my
phone will you marry me
the agreement did not cover marriage my
apologies that makes me sad I'm sorry
she's cold